- I'm also worried that
I'll have diarrhea.
- [Jen] Oh, are you lactose intolerant?
- Oh fuck, I am!
(classical music)
- [Woman] I love hot cheetos,
they're like my favorite snack.
- I'm excited to taste, like,
the crunchy and spiciness
against the milk.
- Growing up as a kid,
they were like a go-to.
- I feel whatever about hot cheetos.
I definitely love milkshakes.
- I probably eat hot cheetos everyday.
They're the perfect
compliment to any sandwich.
- Bring 'em on, buddy, let's go.
(classical music)
- This is interesting.
- It looks like it's gonna be delicious.
It's got this, it's like
a strawberry milkshake.
- Cheers!
- [Woman] Mmmm.
That is bomb.
- [Man] Huh, oh, the spicy kicked in.
- That's so good.
- I'm so confused.
(laughter)
- One of the worst things
I've ever felt in my mouth.
- If you think about it too much,
you're definitely, you're gonna throw up.
- Do you have hot cheetos here right now?
- It's actually really good.
My mind keeps trying to
say strawberry milkshake.
- It tastes so sweet,
but then like it gives
you that kick of like
"I'm hot cheetos, but I'm
also very sweet, too!"
- Honey, we are eating two
different types of milkshake.
- This is more, oh,
someone kind of chewed
a bunch of hot cheetos
and then just spit them in this.
- It's actually good,
and if you love spicy food,
like people that eat
like tubs of spicy ramen,
you would totally like this.
- [Woman] It lived up to my expectations
and I want this all day, all night.
- No, just no.
- I'm a little let down.
I really thought it was gonna be great.
- I thought I'd like wanna
throw up after a first sip,
but I could drink more of this.
She almost finished hers.
- [Jen] I have no standards, so.
- This is now the fifth most
disgusting blended thing
you have made me consume!
- [Man Offscreen] It's only the second!